نعم اكيد قابلت الامير محمد وامراه اخرى
يعني عده مرات شو اللي لفت نظرك في شخصيه
الامير محمد بن سلمان في لقاءاتك مع دكتور
شخصيه كاريزماتيه يعني هو شخص اولا
اول مره
قابلته ذكرني بالرئيس الامريكي اللي هو
يعني سياسي مخضرم عنده عنده امكانيه انه
يحسس الشخص اللي بيتكلم معه انهم مهم فهذه
يعني خصله مهمه عندك كاريزماتيه بالاضافه
الى يعني طاقه
يعني طاقه خارقه او او كبيره جدا
عندما يتكلم عن رؤيته للبلد والتغييرات في
البلد انا ما عندي بصراحه شك انه هو
اهتمامه بالبلد وطموحه للبلد
يعني منبعه
يعني عنده يعني عنده
نيه خالصه وصادقه انه بده يحسن بلده بده
يطور بلده وبده يدافع عن مصالح بلده
كيف وجدت التغييرات اللي حصلت في السعوديه
دكتور من 2015 منذ الاعلان عن الرؤيا الى
اليوم يعني
ليك انا بقولها دائما في امريكا انه لو في
2010 مثلا
قلت لي انه بتحصل التغييرات هذه
التغييرات خاصه الاجتماعيه اللي حصلت كنت
بقول لك بال 2010 لانه بتحصل حرب اهليه في
البلد يعني هذه تغييرات كبيره جدا ولكن
والحمد لله يعني انه ما حصل ما حصل عنف ما
حصلت حرب اهليه البلد تطور وتغير